[Music]
when you have high emotional
intelligence how do you ensure you don't
inadvertently use it for manipulation or
come off as manipulative to others
you know this is one of those words it's
not good or bad yes we're constantly
manipulating that's right if i'm telling
mariah i love her i want her to know
that i love her
if i'm if i'm if i'm doing something for
her
uh making a meal or whatever it is like
i'm going on my way taking her out on a
date i'm manipulating her right but it's
not it's not in a
disingenuous way so maybe that's the
question it's not coercive either right
manipulation is often coercive and
that's how you would unlove someone is
to coerce them into doing something that
they don't want to do trying to change
them actually means you hate the person
if you want someone to change you don't
love who they are
and therefore it's an unloving posture
now one might actually make the argument
here that to coerce someone or to
manipulate someone in the way
that caitlyn's talking about is
emotionally unintelligent anyway because
if you're intelligent enough emotionally
then you'd have no desire to manipulate
others because
what you're doing when you manipulate
them is saying i need to have power over
you i need dominion over you
in order for me to be happy or here's a
lot of hubris which is really
emotionally unintelligent
is
oh i know what's best for you and even
though if you don't recognize it i know
what's best for you i know if we just
make these decisions together this would
be better for you and maybe it would
but a man convinced against his will is
of the same opinion still yeah dale
carnegie makes me think of uh
there's this show called the shrink next
door
with paul rudd and will ferrell okay
really good man and it's a true story
about the shrink who manipulates a
patient basically i saw a billboard for
this at one point yeah and uh
yeah it's it's
a the the fascinating thing about it is
it's a true story but you see this
shrink who essentially manipulates
someone for their own personal gain and
it's at the patient's detriment
so what you just described was exactly
how it comes across i know i'm i i'm the
one who knows what you need you don't
know what you need
and uh that i think that is when that is
when manipulation turns
um evil in a way really or uh or yeah it
turns into coercion is when you are
putting
someone else
at it
when you're doing something uh making
someone else do something at their
detriment for your own personal gain
like that is where you can look at it
and be like okay this probably isn't the
right thing to do yeah or if you're just
making someone else do anything in
general yeah because it's easy for us to
justify and say oh yeah this isn't to
their detriment
but my desire to change you says a whole
lot more about me than it does about who
you are as a person yeah not only do i
have perfect ownership of myself but i
need to have a little bit of ownership
over you
in order for me to
manipulate you to coerce you to persuade
you to be more like me yeah all kinds of
hubris than that we got to be careful
and if we let go of the hubris we let go
of the desire to change other people now
why do we try to change other people is
because quite often we're so afraid of
looking inward and changing ourselves
it's so much easier to change
danny or alabama or jacob or podcast
sean or jordan
well in theory
yes it's easier for us to move our hands
around as though we're doing something
productive right
as though being productive was the goal
in the first place it's absurd we don't
want to be more productive especially
with the people in our lives the people
in our lives are not products and our
love is not transactional
coercing someone
is trying to change them
to meet my standards yeah but what if
they have completely different standards
from me they have different desires they
have different interests they're a
completely different person and they are
complete without me i don't need to drag
them where i am you mentioned compassion
earlier what does that mean calm and
pass us to be with someone during their
suffering
to be with someone during their
suffering not to suffer
like them
not to suffer with them
but to be with them and acknowledge that
we're all suffering in some way yeah did
you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel hundred
percent advertisement free